Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P
my story from the bonus show about French toast.
Holla. I'm sorry. Holla. French toast. Got the
egg, man. Thinking back to his time in prison. As
many of you know, the egg man man's been calling
into the show for 15 years, and he spent some time
in prison for drug related charges. And he often
has interesting stories. Here's one of them.
Speaker 3: I would kill for some French brand
Hala. Right now, A.J., when I was in prison,
because I was you. I made the foul bread for
the Jewish guys. Right. So I would go in the
kitchen, you know, once we gave you every
couple of weeks between the couple and when I make
it, we add in yeast. Except only the guards could
have power over the yeast, so they would dump
it. Houston, big mess. They even mix it in a
little bit so we couldn't take it out. Of course
I would take it out and I would trade it to the
Native Americans. They would make alcohol with the
yeast that I gave them, and then they would trade
us cannabis. So the Jews would get high on Shabbat
instead of, you know, have good color. However,
with half the yeast, alcohol still came out and
it was still okay. We did a good job. Your baby
and the collar were both items. Shalom, brother.
Speaker 1: All right, so the egg man with an
explosive look at the training that took
place when he was when he was in prison.
We should really have egg man on. He has the best
story. I know he wants to keep himself private,
but I think he could he could tell us some very
interesting stories. We have a great bonus show
coming up for you today. Sign up at join pacman
dot com to get instant access to the bonus stuff.